hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're going to be talking about battery
tips and by battery tips i mean mostly
tips that are going to help you get your
battery to last longer on devices like
smartphones and tablets now right off
the bat i just want to know there's no
like magical cure or magical thing that
you can do to your device typically
there's nothing crazy you can do to get
an extra million and a half hours out of
it or get it to last all day if it only
lasts three or four hours to begin with
but there are some things you can keep
an eye on to keep your battery from
draining a lot of devices just drain the
battery for seemingly no reason you can
keep an eye on some things to stop that
first thing you want to note is the
radios in your device are you using a 4g
device or a 3g device or an hspa plus
device or are you keeping it on wi-fi
only for the most part and this is a
general rule 4g radios use the most
amount of power and that uses a little
bit more than 3g radios and those 3g
radios use a little bit more than wi-fi
only radios if you have a 4g device
keeping it on your wi-fi network when
you're at home is going to save a lot of
battery it's only a 3g device switching
it to wi-fi may get you a little bit
more battery but it won't be as drastic
as a difference and if it's a wi-fi only
tablet some tablets actually have the
option to turn off wi-fi when they're
asleep this will probably stop you from
getting notifications if you need that
internet access to get your app data but
you'll be able to get a little bit more
battery if you turn wi-fi off when the
device is asleep but as a general rule
of thumb disable any radios that you're
not using like bluetooth or gps if you
don't need it or things like that
next is a cpu and this is a sort of a
silent behind the scenes killer
sometimes there's wake locks going on
where your screen is off but the cpu is
doing things some devices like for
example the asus transformer pad
infiniti have performance modes high
performance mode lets the cpu go all the
way up to the highest 1.7 gigahertz
balanced mode will let it go up to maybe
1.4 gigahertz and battery saver mode
will tend to limit it to more like 1
gigahertz the harder your cpu is working
the more cycles it's going through the
more battery you're going to be using so
as a general rule of thumb for cpu
basically try to keep it as low as you
need to if you're losing battery life
now if it's possible on your platform
you can actually use an application to
look at how much battery each individual
application is using on your device
actually with android it's built into
the operating system and if you take a
look at this you will almost always find
that the number one battery killer on
tablets on smartphones even on wi-fi
only laptops chromebooks mobile devices
that use batteries is the display
keeping a huge panel backlit for that
long and letting you use it and being
responsive and constantly changing and
shifting pixels and colors and
everything takes the most battery out of
anything so your screen is what is
killing your battery i can almost
guarantee that
so here is one of my favorite apps for
that it's called battery widget reborn
don't snicker at that but it gives us a
shortcut to the android battery usage
and this will tell you what's been using
the most battery on your device so you
can scroll down to the bottom here gmail
uses some battery
chrome uses some
maps uses some and above all our screen
is what's using the most we click on our
screen and you can see how long our
screen has been on that's our screen on
time one hour and three minutes of
actually using the phone while the
display is on so to get your display to
use less battery you can do a couple
things number one big thing you can do
is display brightness a lot of phones
have automatic brightness and that tends
to be a little bit aggressive and keeps
the display brightness below what you
tend to think it should be but you can
still read what's on the screen second
thing you can do is just use manual
display brightness so if you know that
you're going to be going outside you can
turn up the display brightness but as
soon as you come back indoors you can
turn down the display brightness because
you don't really need it that bright
indoors the second thing is screen
timeout and your screen might time out
after maybe 30 seconds or a minute after
you don't do anything and it just turns
the display off and that might not seem
like a lot but you can actually turn
that down on pretty much every device
out there that has a screen so you can
turn it down to maybe 10 or 15 seconds
and that'll save you a lot more battery
than usually people think it does and a
little niche tip if you're using an oled
display like for example the galaxy s3
does all the pixels that are black are
not lit up so if you use a black
background you won't have to light any
of those pixels if you use the black
themed applications not gray gray
doesn't help but black themed then those
pixels don't get lit up and you'll be
saving a lot of battery with black apps
and black wallpaper ever since i've
gotten my nexus 7 and i just use it
around the house for checking like
twitter or using maps or little things
like that i notice that my phone i end
the day with 35 to 45 battery without
any attempt to conserve so definitely a
tip i know it's not an option for
everyone to you know have a spare device
because obviously that's like a spare
battery but know that that usually helps
quite a bit now i'm realizing if you're
on an iphone you can do almost none of
the things that i just said you can do
if you're on an android device or maybe
if you're on windows phone the only
thing i would suggest is auto brightness
auto brightness a lot of times will take
your screen brightness way below what
you think it should take that off auto
brightness use manual brightness control
add a widget oh wait no keep a shortcut
on your home screen so you can go to the
brightness settings and always have that
handy and turn your display down when
you don't need it to be that bright so
there you go guys those are some tips on
how to save battery on your mobile
device let me know what kind of battery
tips you have or what kind of battery
life you get i know some people will be
like oh i have a droid and it gets like
no battery but
bear with me you can try some of the
tips i gave and hopefully it'll help you
out give a thumbs up if this does help
and go ahead and try some of these tips
either way thanks for watching and i'll
talk to you guys in the next video
peace
you